mais quand même large partie de ma vie
ou franchement je me sentais pas
spécialement français
[Musique]
je
je suis dingue ça et je suis venu ici
quand j'avais 10 ou 11 ans et quand on
est arrivé ici
le projet c'était des études et puis on
a idéalisé on se dit voilà on va vivre
dans un super pavillon variés une vie
meilleure et c'est en fait ne s'est pas
passé comme ça devait c'était quartier
hlm prépare et est du coup un moment
tourmalet des frères buteur des cousines
qui tourne mal à des vacances les
expulsions le conflit perpétuel avec
l'administration
la stigmatisation quand tu échanges avec
avait pour djoko d'échangés que police
et cetera
et puis après il est décrit comme fin de
ta vie qui cliquent change et qui sont
liées à un attentat personnalité
par exemple moi je sais que mon fils il
est né bizarrement je me suis senti un
peu plus français
je me voyais moins dans le discours de
hu m10 est chez toi c'est pas ici c'est
hot ne s'est pas totalement ici
effectivement le congo c'est chez lui
nous fêtons bréau jusqu'à preuve du
contraire où effectivement on voit de
temps en temps au congo et sa réalité
plus française devant quoi des gens que
vous appelez des enfants de la répéter
parce qu'ils sont français qui ont
grandi en france comment ça se fait
qu'ils ont la déchéance de siffler
l'hymne peut-être parce qu'il ya un
malaise dans le pays et que peut-être le
pays les accus pas dans le dans le
dans le projet national parce
qu'effectivement les mêmes par contre
quand il voit un modèle de réussite
comme résident à nous laver le chine est
vite fait écrire en fait l'équipe ils
n'ont pas le problème est que non pas
ils ont pas un problème est que le
groupe france ils ont approuvé avec
saint certains symboles qui est un des
moments les a réduits ou les stigmatiser
ou les a humiliés dans leur histoire
récente ou un peu plus ancienne et quand
on parle d'enfants de la république
c'est tous ensemble
par contre dans les faits quand il faut
regarder les choses n'ont quand même il
ya des prioritaires et où est ce double
discours
en fait en fait c'est simple et c'est ça
qui nous empêchent d'avancer et de
regarder les choses en face tu vois on a
vraiment l'impression que dans les faits
c'est le fait que les gens soient
différents et variés qui fait qu' il s'
apprennent des choses mais eux les uns
aux autres qui se soustraient pas qu'ils
se complètent
mon voeu formater des trucs quand la
france mène 4 à 5 minutes du coup
d'envoi du l'idée d'une finale de coupe
du monde et que tu commences pourtant
des branches en scène omar fais comment
être un français quand tu connais par
coeur la chanson des restos du coeur
c'est un vin français quand tu
tu connais des génériques de club
dorothée parker ou 1h30 le voit doter
enfin demandé d'y aller j'ai en mode
c'est toute ma vie c'est que tu as un
peu un vrai français quand tu commences
à râler dès que quelqu'un veut passer
devant toi sur le périph français des
embouteillages et terrain tu commence à
devenir un vrai français
ah oui quand on commence à regarder
joséphine ange gardien suivant c'est le
jour des funérailles de venise mais ces
chantiers français
merde je peux avec des mecs long des
chemins des t-shirts avec le des loups
dessus pour moi c'était ça culinaire
français c'est ce jour là c'est pas ce
jour là que des françaises par le
prendre comme ça mais ces ouvrages lui
tu es tu es français jean franchouillard